brand new twists in the Biden doc drama
resurface video shows Hunter Biden
jetting off to the president's
Wilmington home just four days before
classified files were found in the
garage next to the Corvette we are also
learning that the president's personal
attorney who found the initial batch of
classified documents was interviewed by
the FBI but the bureau skipped out on
filing an official document called a
302. the government uses those to
summarize interviews basically meaning
that the FBI may have acted more
informally and sources confirming to Fox
News that despite claims from the White
House that they can't talk about the
investigation the doj says there is no
gag order so they're not being
forthcoming about that judge
you know I it is I think that Jonathan
Turley used the word breathtaking I use
the word stunning they have decided the
Department of Justice has decided that
this is going to go nowhere and
therefore they will not follow the rules
normally there's a charade that goes on
so it appears that they're following the
rules here the Department of Justice has
come right out and they said look you
know we'll let your lawyers collect the
documents and Sauber the lawyer Biden's
lawyer said you know he said I don't
have clearance and yet saber was given
the authority by the Department of
Justice to collect the documents so
we've got this you know I'm tired of you
talking about two-tier Justice I think
the bigger issue today is the Department
of Justice doesn't care what you think
they're not even going to make believe
that they're being fair they've got a
guy whose son is collecting money I'm
not going to go through it again and who
is under federal investigation for money
laundering with 150 transactions a test
or noticed by the department of the
treasury and they're basically telling
the family you just police yourself
everything's okay we're not going to
come in in the early morning and you
don't your lawyers do it we're Trump's
lawyers were outside that wouldn't even
let them in the room you know and here's
the question that I have done Dana
apparently that Penn Center was not open
until 2017.
okay the Penn Biden Center so if those
documents were taken out of the White
House in 2016 when Joe Biden left
because their Obama classified documents
where were they for that year before
they arrived at the Penn Center which is
Chinese run in terms of the money I'm
yeah unless they unless they took them
out in January of 2017 and then I I
don't know they were definitely
somewhere before that office was open
they were somewhere before the office
was open so we've got a doj that we know
lied to the fisa court the doj lied to
the American people the doj has been you
know they but now they're they don't
even want to hide it from you you know
Joe's a good guy
um and the D.A now the the doj is now
saying we were on site no you weren't
you told us lawyers to take it it's very
sad one of the things Jesse is that
among the questions that the White House
says that they can't answer is how many
documents were found whether there may
still be documents out there what was
contained in them and why the public
wasn't notified after they were
discovered and that's the White House
yeah at the White House and they're like
we've been fully transparent we've
answered everything that we possibly
could except for the answers to those
four questions just if you say you're
cooperating and you're transparent
doesn't mean you actually are this is
the Hillary Playbook remember her people
were like smashing blackberries with
hammers and giving it to the feds here I
dropped it or they were having the
lawyers look through it they're like all
right you know what the rest is personal
and fell in bleach or they interview
Hillary at the end of the investigation
and they forget to hit the record button
and then here you have a doj guy be like
you know what our uh FBI guys are busy
framing Trump I'm just gonna stand out
here in the driveway smoke cigarettes
while you lawyers go look for stuff I
don't want to interfere with the big
guy's office all right so what'd you
find uh-huh uh-huh oh don't worry I'm
not writing any of this down you can say
whatever you want I'll make it up later
right so they go back to Justice and
then they call the New York Times and
they say this is how these documents are
different than the Trump documents okay
and here's what I love about Washington
you can have the Chinese spend the night
at the Trump Hotel bring up some room
service a couple thousand and the
Democrats want to impeach Donald Trump
for that Trump was tough on China you're
right Biden can come in and the Chinese
can pour a hundred million dollars into
pen pen Biden Center he can go soft on
China and the Democrats are like eating
cookies while they're running away from
reporters
Harold what are you and the judge
Whispering about over there so the judge
was was making a point a couple points
about the dates uh in this matter which
which I find to me to be the most
interesting thing November 2nd and
November 14th and from November 14th
when the U.S attorney in Illinois he was
a republican appointed U.S attorney and
I believe President Trump was assigned
to look into this the November 2nd
finding from November 14th to January
5th something happened because then
attorney general Garland said we need a
special counsel for this matter it's
unclear to me all this happened was it
clear was it only Optics and you wanted
to ensure that you were being fair in
that regarded was there some sort of
legal permission to talk about legality
or legal matters here just it was their
legal matter that did it what the judge
was saying salber Richard Sauber has
legal clearance security clearance but
what you were saying I think was that
the lawyers at the doj sent to the vice
president's home in Wilmington to
oversee I believe Mrs Albert said watch
him do this they didn't have security
clearance so if there was some something
found those doj lawyers couldn't could
not interact people at the Penn Center
who found it also didn't have security
clearance right so so let me so I think
the transparency thing here is is
problematic I think Democrats who don't
believe this is serious you're not being
serious and for Republicans who
immediately try to compare this to
president Trump's matter you're not
being totally honest about this I hope
that her the the special counsel here uh
and I think the most important thing in
your intro uh Thanos when you said the
doj said there's no gag order on the
White House if that is indeed the case
uh I think there's some questions that
that are that weren't answers uh and I
feel sorry for Michonne Pierre because
she doesn't either know the answers or
and or is not able to no let's go in her
a Lifeline not even the doj so some
there's some questions that and that's
one of the questions that Jackie
Heinrich asked this afternoon and she
said is it safe to say that there is a
national security analysis or assessment
going on about whether or not these
documents could have posed a threat to
the country and Mr could not answer
these are questions that if we were
Democrats and this was Mr Trump we would
want these answers that was another
point that was brought up today that
there was supposed to be we are waiting
a national security analysis that the
dni is supposed to do about the Trump
documents and that's never been revealed
and Byron York brought that up today and
then we had this other information that
Hunter was there just four days before
Hunter and the reporters like you can't
talk about him because he's like you
know innocent was you don't want to talk
about the president's family how dare
you what happened to you uh he's in the
garage it all makes sense now the
paintings make sense Hunter goes to the
garage gets the classified documents
slips it between the frame and the
painting sells it to the anonymous
donors for a half a million dollars who
are they Chinese but we don't know that
I know I'm you know this is Hammer told
me this in the bathroom
you know I you know it might take it for
what it's worth but he's been right on
all of this stuff at the very beginning
and Harold you say don't compare it to
Trump because it's not totally honest
how dare you sir come back from a
splendid long weekend and say something
like that Joe was at the height of his
self-righteousness about Trump's
classified document problem so he
deserves exactly the Wrath he was egging
on remember he wasn't just talking about
the documents he blew it up so that it
was about fascism about a threat to
democracy about Trump's supporters about
the remember the uh that dark speech as
well he was talking about how like there
was a shroud of Darkness you know and
and the possibility of nuclear codes the
damage to society so I believe in
self-righteous reciprocity
[Laughter]
everybody gets a free punch right Joe
Biden deserves he deserves a punch for
this right in the kisser right in the
kisser and by the way that's a metaphor
for you people but it's a fact is you
know all the people that were wrongly
accused or smeared they have a free
punch they get that you know you may
think that there's nothing to this I
don't care Harold I didn't put that in
your your tie I I said it seriously oh
I'm not disagreeing with you I mean I've
had it with you Harold had it with you
you're so divisive but it is good to
have you back at the table I wanna Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now